- We are back and our next guest
have been putting out high
octane rock and soul music
for nearly 25 years.
You know them for hits
like "How You Like Me Now",
which was used in
countless movies, TV shows,
and commercials.
Their new album, "AMEN"
just dropped this week,
and is a really good one.
- [Guest] Hey that's a
good album title, Kelly.
I like that.
- Is it?
I thought you might like it.
- [Guest] Oh, yeah.
I'ma listen to that one.
Oh yeah.
(Kelly laughing)
(audience laughing)
- Okay, now performing
"Stone Cold Killer."
Give it up for The Heavy.
(audience cheering and applauding)
(upbeat rock music)
♪ Ow ♪
♪ Hey ♪
♪ My heart's like a flame to
the sound of the voice in you ♪
♪ You got the hooks, got the claws ♪
♪ Got me begging you to light the fuse ♪
♪ Hell ♪
♪ I got my mind on my honey ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah ♪
♪ I got my honey on my mind ♪
♪ It feel good, but it feels
like I'm caught in the lights ♪
♪ At the scene of a crime feel
like a stone cold killer ♪
♪ You're cold as ice ♪
♪ Oh, like a stone cold killer ♪
♪ You don't think, don't think twice ♪
♪ The temperature is rising ♪
♪ It's too hot to touch, oh ♪
♪ You never know desire ♪
♪ Until it burn in a rub ♪
♪ And caught up in a crossfire ♪
♪ And leave me hanging by a thread ♪
♪ And take me to the river ♪
♪ And leave me for dead ♪
♪ Like a stone cold killer ♪
♪ You're cold as ice ♪
♪ You don't think, don't think twice ♪
(guitar solo)
♪ I know, I know, I know ♪
♪ You're like a stone cold killer ♪
♪ You're cold as ice ♪
♪ Oh, like a stone cold killer ♪
♪ You don't think twice ♪
♪ You're like a stone cold killer ♪
♪ You're cold as ice ♪
♪ You like a stone cold killer ♪
♪ You don't think, don't think ♪
♪ You're like a stone cold killer ♪
♪ You're cold as ice ♪
♪ You don't think, don't think ♪
♪ Stone cold killer ♪
♪ You're cold as ice ♪
♪ You're like a stone cold killer ♪
♪ You don't think, don't think ♪
(audience cheering and applauding)
- Once more, put your hands together
for The Heavy, everybody.
Their new album "AMEN" is out now,
and they're about to kick off a US tour.
Y'all got to check it out,
so look online for tickets and dates.
We will be right back
with What I'm Liking.